when knowing how to learn is considered
a core life skill that no one's actually
willing to teach and when the speed at
which you grasp things is considered to
be a measure of your intelligence it's
no wonder that so many of us are left
feeling that we are stupid and slow and
unintelligent
when I truly believe that if you've only
ever had terrible teaching your whole
life you can't say for sure that you are
a bad learner or a slow learner because
you've never actually been given a
proper chance at this and I'm definitely
not an expert teacher or a teacher by
any stretch of the imagination but as
someone who has had to get a very
distractible brain through life and
medical school I do have quite a bit of
experience with having to teach things
to someone very fast and so if you're
also looking into new learning methods
and if for whatever reason you want to
optimize for Speed and your brain works
like mine here's what works for me and
how I conceptualize and teach myself
things and think of information in a way
that optimizes for doing things as fast
as possible let's just get straight into
it now there are four main steps in my
learning the first two of which are
almost invisible because I think not a
lot of people do them not a lot of
people realize that I do them and when
they catch me in step three step four
they think oh my God she's so fast at
learning when it's not the same because
they haven't done the first two steps
that I keep doing every time so I'm
going to jump straight into them these
two first ones I think are the absolute
most important so the very first I call
safety netting this is where I focus on
things like emotions limits implications
and connections for everything that I'm
due to learn and I create a specific
space in my brain for that thing where I
understand the very very basics of it
and how it connects to everything else
in a way that creates the best surface
and priming for me to be able to add
information on later and I'm going to
explain how I do this in detail and why
basically I've observed a lot of
learning in my life and I've kind of
seen how fast or slow it can be and when
it is effective and ineffective and the
fastest most effective learning I have
ever seen in my life actually happens in
the doctor's office so what happens is
that you can see a very good doctor in
two or three minutes give a patient a
complete crash course in a medical
condition that they knew nothing about
and they just become so empowered in
understanding everything about it they
might not have known anything about
asthma before they walked into the
office but once they leave they know
what it is why they might have it what
how it affects them what to do with it
what medications to take how to take
those medications what might go wrong
what to do when those things go wrong
where to go when those things go wrong
what further testing might be needed who
the other Specialties that are involved
are it's just completely insane and you
see these patients within three minutes
basically understand more about their
clinical condition than I sometimes know
as a medical student with a foundation
in physiology and anatomy and all of
that stuff so it's absolutely incredible
this is the best teaching that I have
ever seen is doctors teaching things to
patients and so I've paid a lot of
attention to what happens here and I've
tried to isolate what are the elements
that make this teaching and learning so
effective and how I can Implement them
for myself and this is the a conclusion
and what I think I do basically when I'm
safety netting something so at the very
first instance when I'm trying to learn
something the questions that I'm going
to ask myself are what are we talking
about and at the very very core in the
simplest terms possible for example
mechanics in physics is about how bodies
move in space and this is the essential
thing like the very very core where this
set so already just by saying this
sentence I know that I can draw from
things that already exist in my mind and
information that is already there and I
can slot this section of physics where
it's supposed to be the same thing with
medical conditions the same thing with
skills like editing I really want to
create a space on what am I doing here
what am I achieving and what am I
learning then I want to go on and see
why this thing is important and how
important is it actually the same thing
when we Safety Net in medicine we tell a
patient well if you don't take the
medication this is what happens if you
skip it this is what happens if things
go bad this is what happens so I want to
have a good measure from knowing nothing
to knowing everything how important is
this what's this used for and how
important are those things so I can
assign it a level of importance in my
mind and therefore allocate it
accordingly next one of the most
important steps in safety netting and
preparing myself to learn something is
understanding the limitations and the
connections of what I'm about to learn
and what I mean by this is that for
example if I'm learning to use a new app
I need to know what I can do when I
become an expert at using this and what
I cannot do even when I'm an expert at
this thing so for example I know with
Final Cut Pro what things I can do and
then if I want to do other animations or
other things what other app do I need to
use this is before I've even started and
the reason for this is that it really
draws upon things that are in my mind
and really helps me conceptualize and
step back and really really see how this
fits in my brain and in my perception of
the world I'm drawing upon things that I
already know desires I already have
needs I already have things that are
already true and established in my brain
rather than starting on a foundation of
nothing and in this way I'm also
connecting things with pre-existing
thoughts in my brain so this also means
that in the future when I'm about to
learn more about this thing I know that
because it's connected to this other app
or because this formula in physics is
also used in this field in mathematics I
know that I can draw on pre-existing
information which will then help me
learn new things a lot faster questions
I also look to answer for myself is
where do I need to go for further
knowledge on this topic once I grasp it
what does an expert in the field
involved in this knowledge look like
this seems like a random one but it
really really helps if you put a name to
the career or the profession that are
involved in whatever you are learning it
can still then help draw upon those
fields and anchor it to different parts
of my brain that are associated with
this thing once I've established what
this thing is about why I should care
about this thing how much I should care
about this thing what I can do once I
learn this thing what I still can't do
one time once I learned this thing what
an expert in this field looks like and
where I can go to get more information
or become more of an expert in this
field I kind of have a very strong
safety net and a very strong mesh in my
brain already about where this
information is going to start sitting
and this very very core thing is kind of
similar to the Feynman technique which
is basically explaining things to a
child but it goes above and beyond that
it's basically focusing on the periphery
and on the context of the thing that
we're about to learn without ever
looking at the specifics themselves
because I don't care about the specifics
yet I want to create a space for the
specifics rather than starting there now
when I am learning in real time the way
that I create the safety net is that for
example if I'm sitting in a lecture on a
topic I never take notes during that
lecture I'm not writing anything down
I'm just sitting down and listening to
what the person is saying and trying to
essentially focus on what the core
skeleton of the point that they're
trying to make is and very often
lecturers are not too good at putting
things in context so I have to do this
work myself while I'm sitting down but
I'm just focusing on the very basic
things which is why when I'm in a
lecture you'll probably see me ask
seemingly stupid questions of the sort
of so what we're talking about is or so
correct me if I'm wrong what you
actually mean is that if this happens
then this happens or you're saying that
the thyroid is important because of
neural development this sounds like a
really basic question but this is the
level that I want to keep things and a
lot of my time investment when I'm
learning goes in this very very very
core because if these foundations are
missing then any sort of details will
have no right to set can be forgotten a
lot faster I'll have to go back to the
basics because I can't connect things
with one another but creating this
strong Foundation means that everything
has its own place I'm much more
empowered in actually understanding
things the way that a patient really
really understands their clinical
condition even though they don't need to
know the anatomy and the physiology of
things they're better able to understand
conceptualize and framework things and
still be highly effective in what
they're trying to do so this is what I
do in the beginning step one safety net
what is this about and what does it mean
how important is it how does it connect
to things in my mind hopefully I can
draw from emotional things so if safety
nets that I'm creating in my brain kind
of trigger parts of my mind that have to
do with for example things that I think
are unjust or things that I have not
resolved in the past or things that I'm
genuinely very invested and curious
about this can add to the energy and the
focus and the attention and therefore
the speed with which I'm able to process
information in the future so I think
this emotional component really adds to
how effectively I can learn things and
how fast I can learn things and this
leads me to my second step which I think
is also equally very underrated and this
is focusing on the core Basics what I
mean by the core Basics are the
applicable rules that are so so simple
that very often people won't even
mention them because they'll assume that
we've known them or learned them in high
school or learned them a very long time
ago or because they are just the bread
and butter that people in lecturers or
doctors or professionals use they don't
even consider that people might not know
these basic things but these are the
things that move the needle the most the
reason I focus some core Basics is
because I've realized very early on in
life that these were the things that
helped people learn fast so for example
I went to a music school when I was
younger for a while and I could see that
people who already knew one musical
instrument were so much better at
learning a new one than people who knew
none at all so even though someone who
was a violinist had never touched a
piano before they'd be so much faster at
learning the piano obviously because
they know how music works and they know
how to read notes and they have a good
conceptualization of the basics of
timing and Rhythm at all of these things
so even though these two instruments are
quite different it gives this person a
big upper hand because they have a good
grasp of the core basics in the same way
if you are a mechanic for example it's a
lot easier for that person to learn to
fix fridges than it is for someone else
who doesn't know anything about this
because they understand the very basics
of things like electricity and how to do
Maneuvers and the little technical
things that they might need in order to
learn this task so I was very often
obsessed since I was younger with very
very poor basic things and this is again
where I spent a lot of my time and when
I still do this so whenever I start a
new subject or a new thing that I need
to learn my mind immediately goes what
is the basic thing here so for example
I'm studying Pediatrics in University
now and I know that when it comes to
Children the most important thing is
they're breathing because that's the
first thing that's effective so
Pediatrics lungs very important
breathing issues in children or I'll
think well in when it comes to
physiology of the kidney the most
important thing is it controls blood
pressure which when I was younger I
thought that the heart control blood
pressure it doesn't it's the kidney so
these very basic things that you really
need to have a strong grasp on in order
to effectively build information in the
future because small things you can
learn here and there but unless you have
these core essential Concepts it becomes
very difficult to build true information
so I really focus on these things the
easiest way that I find and isolate the
core Basics are if I'm lucky to have an
expert who I can talk to who's quite
insightful I will ask them what's the
bread and butter of the things that you
do or what are the clinical conditions
that you see three to four times a day
or what's something that you do every
single week without fail and if I don't
have access to these sorts of things I
become very good at judging experts at
what they're doing so for example in
order for me to become a good video
editor I didn't have access to any I
would just look at a lot of YouTube
videos and go what are the small things
that really identified a professional
editor from a non-professional one and
that doesn't tend to be weird little
animation things it very often is how
tight is their a cut so it's kind of
realizing what are the things that move
the needle the most and how quickly can
I grasp these things I then will spend a
lot of time focusing on the basics for
example in maths if I learn a formula
and then I learn a new chapter in
trigonometry I'm not going to learn the
new formulas yet I'm going to try and
use the ones that I already know which
very often I can't do because I need the
new formulas but basically then I also
understand the limits of the information
that I already have what it can be used
what it cannot be used for so so I have
these really strong core basics in mind
and a very strong toolbox on which to
build things and I have a very core
basic language and understanding and
familiarity with whatever kind of Niche
and thing I'm trying to learn which
gives me a huge kind of leg up in what
I'm trying to do even without knowing
all of the extreme things or all of the
complicated things these are the first
two most important steps that I do in
any learning ever I sit down and I think
what is this about and where will this
slot in my brain and what are the
easiest things and the most important
things that I can learn about this that
I can grasp first and as I become very
impatient with learning these things I
then have a much stronger familiarity
with the things that I'm about to learn
and I'm in a very good position to then
build on this information later so this
is where step three most people will see
me and think oh my God she's so fast but
that's because they're just starting at
step three I've done step one and two so
with all of this information I go into
the rest of the categorization which
from me falls into two more groups which
are admin and good for you so basically
whenever I'm approaching a book or
anything to learn I will kind of divide
all of the information into different
groups so first will be the safety net
which is kind of the backbone and the
skeletal Logic the second group is the
core Basics these are things that I have
to grasp as soon as possible before I do
anything else the third group is admin
and this depends on the person but I
know that I really struggle learning new
words and numbers and things like that
while I find Concepts very easy to learn
so if I'm trying to learn fast all of
the words and the numbers I'll just say
this is admin I'll learn it later and I
won't let them hold me back but I'll
focus on learning the logic because I'm
the sort of person who can study a whole
like disease or condition and I'll know
everything about it but I would not be
able to tell you what it's called so
I'll put this name of it in the admin
category of I'll learn this later when I
have the time or when it's important but
I'm not going to let it hold them back
so any small thing that holds you back
I'd slot it in the admin category and
lastly is the good for you category and
these are the things which it sounds bad
to say but are kind of not relevant are
not important at all almost in most of
the cases and you're not interested in
them and these go in the good for you
category so there are things that are
kind of not important and not relevant
but I'm very curious and interested in
in which case I will learn them anyway
and they become admin or core Basics but
the things that are kind of irrelevant I
don't care about I don't mind if people
know them and I don't basically and they
just fall into this category because any
field is completely endless so there is
definitely going to be a huge amount of
stuff that fall in there so once I do
this thing every time that I'm
approaching information I can just scan
through it using Speedway reading I
actually have a video on how I speed
read somewhere I just scan through
everything with speed reading and I slot
it into these categories automatically
and then I know that I can start doing
my actual learning which is create my
safety net create my core Basics and
establish those then focus on the admin
and building on these things quite fast
and then the things that fall into good
for you I just don't care about I might
be familiar or not depending on how my
interests vary and the topic that I am
trying to learn and this is how I appear
to be a fast learner I think and how I
kind of Empower myself and categorize
things in this way also essential to
this is the concept of Jumpy learning
and strategic drowning which I talk
about in detail in another video which
I'll cure just to not waste your time
but that is basically that I don't study
things in the order that they are given
to me I study things in the order that I
am interested in them because my
attention is a very limited resource and
if I am going through things in the
order that they are given but I'm not
interested in them I am burning learning
through my motivation and my attention
to the point that very quickly I'll have
to stop but if I preserve my motivation
and my attention because I am going
wherever it goes it always stays at a
maximum level and I will learn in a
non-linear way but I will only stop when
I'm tired rather than stopping when my
motivation runs out because it almost
never does so in that way even though I
might start a chapter one go to chapter
9 chapter 7 chapter 8 chapter 3 chapter
2 chapter 5. it doesn't matter I'll jump
back and forth in the way that makes
sense to me because I have the core
Basics and my Foundation is very very
solid it's very easy with me to just
have my core Basics and then I'll be
able to approach any chapter of the book
and it will still make sense because I
know where these things will slot and
fit in in the majority of the cases so
this is how I kind of organize things in
my brain now the one last thing I want
to expand on in this video is where to
find good core Basics because I think
this is something that I find quite
frustrating I wish people wrote whole
books or had full courses on just the
very basic things that are the most
essential things in any sort of field
that you're trying to learn because they
would make life a lot easier but I don't
often find them and the kind of hack
that I use very often is that I go and
look at very Advanced things that really
challenge my core Basics or they assume
that I know the core Basics to a level
that they become very well established
so for example when I used to be in high
school I used to watch a lot of
University lectures and biological
topics or I used to watch documentaries
that were really Advanced I don't really
care about the specifics of remembering
the details of what's going on there but
because they use very high level basic
formulas or basic knowledge on biology
and Physiology it then meant that my
knowledge of these things was
established very very well and so very
relevant to this video is curiosity
stream which are very kindly sponsoring
it and this is a website which has a
whole bunch of documentaries on so many
topics I've gone through quite a few in
medicine and in genetics and they are a
perfect way of really really
establishing your knowledge on these now
the reason I very goodlessly promote
curiosity stream for people with low
attention spans for me is not only for
the documentaries but because for the
price of just one takeaway for a whole
year you also get access to nebula which
is where educational creators like
myself post our videos in a space that
is completely ad free nebula is a
platform that doesn't even have an
algorithm and so when I go there I know
that I am able to just watch the thing
that I came for with minimal
distractions which I find is super super
effective and so you can have access to
both of them which hopefully would be a
good companion for your online learning
probably with you and me do a lot of
online learning on the internet at the
moment I found these two resources to be
a perfect companion for myself teaching
so there will be a link in my
description if you want to check that
out but otherwise if you made it so far
thank you so much for spending this time
with me I hope you have a wonderful
every day because yourself and others I
don't believe everything you think
thanks thanks bye